l'exil de soleil cet après midi sur
toute l'europe les conditions n'étaient
pas idéales les filets à paris pour les
salariés du secteur de l'armement
mondial de l'automobile les américaines
se font discrètes pour mieux s'imposer
thalassothérapie une pratique de plus en
plus recherchée par les cadres stressés
qu'ils veulent retrouver leur tenue
quelques jours voilà monsieur bonsoir
la prochaine aura lieu en 1999 elle sera
totale la dernière a eu lieu cet après
midi elle était partiel il s'agit de
l'éclipsé de soleil qu'on a pu observer
de l'extrême nord du canada à l'est de
la méditerranée et bien entendu au
dessus de la france même si elle a pu
parfois passer inaperçu jean-claude
allanic bernie mairie
il y avait ceux qui étaient en extase
devant le soleil ce qui était venu en
touriste et qui en profitait pour
bronzer ceux pour qui c'était la
première fois et ce qui en avait vu
d'autres et puis il y avait aussi les
amateurs éclairés
bien décidé à ne pas en manquer une
miette et je vois donc le disque solaire
qui commence à être masqués par la lune
il est un peu plus de 15h et c'est parti
pour une course qui va durer deux heures
entre la lune et le soleil et c'est
vraiment génial
ces superbes vues de terre une éclipse
partielle c'est aussi une superbe leçon
de choses aussi bien pour les grands que
pour les petits
on ne va pas manquer et qui consentent
elle a une compétence concentrer le
soleil qui ne cachait pas la ligne il
est 16h la lune a déjà réussi à
grignoter presque la moitié du soleil et
14 minutes ce sera du bon sens
ok bien je trouve ça vraiment
fantastique
c'est très impressionnant puis là il ya
des télescopes on peut voir m'emmener
télescope des gens tout le monde sait
c'est vraiment très très bien je trouve
ça épatant j'ai hâte d'être en 1999 pour
la prochaine éclipse totale
et oui comme le soleil et la lune sont
décidément inséparables depuis la nuit
des temps ils ont déjà fixé leur
prochain rendez-vous galant ce sera dans
trois ans à 11 août
les parisiens n'étaient pas les seuls
rassurez vous observez les clips de cet
après midi là voici observée au dessus
du capitole à toulouse place de la
mairie
et puis en descendant plus bas vers le
sud de l'italie par dessus l'épaule d'un
carabinier d'une très jolie fille et
enfin au dessus de la ville sainte de
jérusalem
il paraît ce soir que c'était là bas
magnifique
a paris il est mis des milliers de
salariés du secteur de l'armement
s'était donné un donné rendez-vous cet
après-midi pour protester contre les
suppressions d'emplois dans leurs
secteurs prévus dans le plan de
restructuration des industries de la
défense nationale les plus gros
bataillons venaient de l'ouest où les
arsenaux maritime comme cherbourg brest
se sent particulièrement visée frédéric
protat jack which la déferlante bretonne
de brest de cherbourg de lorient ils
sont arrivés par milliers dans la
capitale pour exprimer leur colère leur
crainte de voir le plan de
restructuration du secteur de l'armement
menacer leurs emplois dépendent d'abord
la dtn
atelier qui est en train de virer il va
durer 60 % du personnel et les machines
alors qu'on est un service rentable donc
vous notre emploi new qu'en tant que
agents des impôts il est aussi supprimé
forcément puisque bon bah quand on est
supprimée la sidérurgie en lorraine ne
le sens des impôts de louis a été rayé
de la carte
en cinq ans le plan du gouvernement
prévoit de supprimer 50 à 75 mille
emplois sur 250 milles des villes comme
cherbourg redoutent d'être sinistrés il
faut faire je suis curé les jamais
comment on fait il faut pas casser
l'outil industriel et il faut tenir
tenir compte de la ville des obligations
de cette ville et je crois que le
président de la république qui nous
reçoit mercredi devrait tenir compte de
cette manifestation d'aujourd'hui
puisque 2500 chambres voix se sont
déplacés à paris pression des
populations
cette manifestation d'ampleur nationale
laisse augurer selon les syndicats un
automne chaud sur le front social est
maintenant l'engagement d'une partie de
bras de fer avec le gouvernement que
nous allons conduire avec le toute la
force et la ténacité nécessaire
on en a assez 3 million deux cent mille
chômeurs vraisemblablement 120 milles de
plus l'année prochaine
il faut arrêter tout ça la semaine
prochaine c'est au tour des
fonctionnaires de descendre dans la rue
scandale à l'évêché de metz
lévesque porte plainte pour abus de
confiance contre son ancien économe
jean claude duyme blood qui par ailleurs
est actuellement directeur des services
fiscaux du département de la moselle il
est soupçonné d'avoir détourné au moins
un million de francs marie-pierre
samitier ludovic fois ça lorsque j'en
fais deux juges lui l'ancien économe de
l'évêché kit hier le bureau du juge
d'instruction
il vient d'être mise en examen pour abus
de confiance il est soupçonné d'avoir
détourné au moins un million de francs
de la trésorerie de l'évêché entre 1990
et 1995
aujourd'hui à metz les réactions sont
unanimes c'est très moche de partir avec
cet argent la major pense que c'est
dégueulasse qu'est ce qu'elle a fait
c'est tout et puis alors en plus ils
avaient quand même belle situation
ce directeur des impôts de la moselle
aurait expliqué aux policiers pendant sa
garde à vue qu'il n'avait pas trouvé
d'autre solution que prendre l'argent de
l'évêché pour financer ses besoins et
ceux de sa famille
plus d'un million de francs envolée
l'enquêté devra déterminer si des sommes
plus importantes sont en jeu l'argent
aurait été détourné par le biais de
chèques émis sur différents comptes
bancaires jean claude chenut sera
entendu par le juge d'instruction mardi
il a donc trois jours pour préparer sa
défense aujourd'hui en angleterre à
gloucester les ouvriers sont venus raser
la maison de l'horreur dont les gravats
ont été dispersées dans une décharge
publique pour effacer toute trace des
crimes du couple l'ouest qui
souvenez-vous avait attiré chez eux au
moins une dizaine d'innocents qui allait
devenir leur victime et cela pendant une
vingtaine d'années sans que personne ne
s'en aperçoive dans le quartier frédéric
ouest s'est suicidé en prison et sa
femme rosemarie purge actuellement une
peine de prison à vie
retour en france les élus de gauche
organisée aujourd'hui dans tout le pays
à des marches de protestation devant les
préfectures pour faire savoir qu'il
n'acceptait pas le désengagement
financier de l'état dans plusieurs
secteurs sur les régions sur les
départements encore sur les communes
reportage
d'après midi à montpellier léo lamberton
françoise maso le maire de sète est un
adepte de la démonstration par l'exemple
quand nous lui avons demandé comment se
traduisent et le désengagement de l'état
et nous a conduits ici devant l'institut
universitaire de technologie installés
sur sa commune
normalement il aurait dû être
intégralement payés par l'état
or premier trailer trop 17 millions
payée exclusivement par la région le
département la collectivité qui a plus a
fourni gratuitement le terrain viabilisé
et bien ici ça qu'ici ça qu'il faut
changer pour changer cela françois
liberti a décidé de manifester et il
n'est pas le seul
cet après midi devant la préfecture de
montpellier 300 élus de gauche se sont
rassemblés avec un mot d'ordre
trop c'est trop lorsqu'on sait que les
collectivités locales assurent
aujourd'hui 107 et qu'elles concernent
des investissements publics dans ce pays
ça montre par conséquent le caractère
particulièrement dangereux de la dérive
au camp nou contre tom maire président
de conseil général sénateur pendant une
heure ils ont expliqué que depuis cinq
ans l'état a la fâcheuse habitude de
leur faire payer des dépenses qu'il
devrait normalement prendre à sa charge
il est facile de dire au niveau national
je baisse les impôts qu'en tant
qu'ancien les responsabilités au niveau
local sans leur assurer les moyens
ces lieux simplicité biblique par
solidarité gouvernementale
les élus de droite n'ont pas participé à
la manifestation mais certains nous ont
avoué qu'ils n'en pensait pas moins
quant aux montpelliérains ils étaient
plus intéressés par les clips ceux du
soleil que par les problèmes financiers
c'était au mois d'août dernier plusieurs
éleveurs de bovins du département de la
vienne décidé de monter à paris avec une
partie de leur troupeau pour expliquer
au président de la république leur
problème conséquences de la crise de la
vache folle jacques chirac les avait
assurés et qu'il trouverait une solution
aujourd'hui un mois et demi plus tard
environ
l'un d'entre eux installés dans la
petite commune de charroux n'a pas perdu
confiance françois privat philipp rytz
une signature au bas d'une page de
cahier d'écolier celle de jacques chirac
un souvenir parmi d'autres de la longue
marche du mois d'août hiver paris
aujourd'hui dans l'esprit de pierre
il reste des regards des rencontres
près de chars ou un village situé à 60
km au sud de poitiers tiers a repris son
activité
il s'occupe d'un troupeau de 250 bêtes
depuis un mois les cours se sont
stabilisés mais il perd toujours 1500 à
2000 francs par tête
associé à son fils damien 27 ans il
s'interroge sur l'avenir des jeunes
même si le président chirac s'est
nettement montré préoccupé par cette
question
le président de la république je peux
pas dire de mensonges c'est parce qu'on
nous a dit les jeunes et on laissera pas
tomber l'agriculture et les jeunes en
particulier
j'essaierai de lui le sont dans des
situations certains articles
carrier des aides tout le temps c'est
bien joli mais bon l'avenir ça changera
rien que ça c'est du court terme non
dans l'année prochaine dans deux ans
dans trois ans il menace que ça se passe
c'est tout moi je veux avoir des
réponses aujourd'hui clair net et précis
savoir si fougueux reste aux plats qui
je dois dégager tous régulièrement
pierre me trouve ses compagnons marchent
ensemble ils attendent les premiers
effets de leur mouvement
si les politiques n'ont pas compris le
message il n'a fait passer mon gros
semaine
on sait que si les questions évidentes
pas rendre mon honneur tech et puis six
mois il m'a dit il ya 4 5 ans qui pourra
jamais faire de vagues
je me serais peut-être pas lancer là
dedans mais aujourd'hui ben j'aime ça
j'ai fait investir ma mère là dedans et
qui baisse on peut on peut rien faire
puis bec moment que ça se passe et on
s'est pas mal bec dans l'eau et puis moi
je sais faire que ça te sont alors à
charroux loin de paris encore plus loin
de bruxelles
ces éleveurs craignent surtout qu'avec
le temps on les oublie
bref encore 40 tonnes d'oignons de quoi
pleurer déversé ce matin devant un
supermarché de la région de dijon
déposée par les professionnels pour
protester contre la chute des cours
selon les producteurs leur union sont
achetés actuellement 60 centimes le kilo
pour être revendus au détail entre 5 et
12 francs le même kilo au mondial de
l'automobile à paris on a beaucoup parlé
des firmes françaises et européennes les
américains sont également très présents
mais disant qu'ils se font 10
créée en présentant des modèles qui
n'ont plus rien de la belle américaine
ugb aziz un claude barret l'eldorado
automobile symbole de la belle
américaine synonyme aussi de rêve et de
curiosité un capot imposant des
calandres rutilante un moteur puissant
c'est la voiture version us tel qu'on se
l'imaginent un véhicule donc peu
adaptées au marché européen en général
et français en particulier dans nos
frontières les ventes de ces voitures
encombrante restent très marginales et
pourtant les américains réussissent une
réelle percée sur notre marché
voici l'exemple le plus marquant le
voyageur chrysler a installé dans ce
monospace un moteur diesel il ya quatre
ans pour répondre au marché français est
donc à sa fiscalité
résultat cette version représente 70%
des ventes et la voiture n'est même pas
fabriqué aux états unis tous les
voyageurs que nous vendons en europe
sont fabriqué en autriche
autre exemple frappant également le
voyageur diesel qui représente encore
une fois la majorité de nos ventes n'est
même pas exporter ni distribuer aux
états unis c'est donc ce que l'on
appelle l'adaptation marchés européens
les prix eux aussi sont maintenant
comparable aux véhicules concurrents sur
notre continent
c'est le résultat d'efforts industriel
conjuguer un dollar devenu abordable
l'amérique peut donc en profiter pour
vendre son rêve et son image une image
souvent créées de toutes pièces en
europe
l'acca de porte par exemple a été
dessiné par un français est fabriqué en
europe et ne doit pas être commercialisé
aux états unis
sur les quatorze modèles que nous
commercialisons en france nous avons
véhicules qui viennent réellement des
états unis sont la preuve d explorer les
produits produits en europe sont
typiquement européen adapté au marché
français en particulier européens et
nous nous exportons quasiment pas en
amérique du nord
d'autres belles américaines comme ce
prototype resteront au pays des rêves
l'actualité internationale à trois
semaines de l'élection présidentielle
aux etats-unis plusieurs milliers des
migrants originaires des pays d'amérique
centrale et du mexique ont convergé
aujourd'hui à washington la capitale
ils sont inquiets des nouvelles lois
restreignant les conditions de leur
accueil dans un pays les états unis qui
s'est toujours voulu très tolérant à cet
égard thierry thulliez de sur place ça
commence comme un concert mais ce n'est
pas un festival de salé
3 encore une démonstration de cuir
indienne traditionnelle c'est bien une
première politique
jamais auparavant ce qu'on appelle ici
les latinos les hispaniques immigré aux
états unis n'avait organisé pareille
manifestation à washington la première
marche où ces immigrés originaires du
mexique de cuba ou d'amérique latine
revendiquent leurs droits comme et loire
américain ya vingt ans je veux rester
ici vous savez il y à une loi qui dit
que la terre n'appartient à personne
d'autre qu'à dieu
il n'y a pas de frontières c'est nous
voulons ce n'est pas une partie du
territoire américain c'est seulement
qu'on va retravailler avoir une vie
décente comme tout le monde
lego illégaux chômeurs ou salariés
ils marchent maintenant vers la maison
blanche son locataire bill clinton a
opposé son veto aux lois républicaines
les plus durs certains d'entre eux se
sont même fait naturalisé américain pour
ne pas être expulsé et pouvoir voter la
majorité des immigrés hispanique 6
millions d'électeurs vont voter bill
clinton aucune loi sur l'immigration
aussi restrictifs soit elle n'a réussi à
freiner le flux des immigrés d'origine
hispanique qui viennent tenter leur
chance aux états unis au point qu'ils
sont aujourd'hui 25 millions à vivre ici
est que l'espagnol est devenue la
seconde langue officieuse du pays en
afghanistan les événements sont
peut-être en train de tourner les
étudiants intégristes les fameux
talibans qui avaient pris facilement
kaboul se trouvent aujourd'hui face à
une contre offensive de toutes les
forces qui leur sont hostiles et qui se
sont alliés pour la circonstance
elles sont regroupées au nord du pays et
des combats ont lieu ce soir à 20
kilomètres à peine de la capitale kaboul
retour en france à la rubrique santé la
thalassothérapie des soins par l'eau une
méthode de remise en forme de plus en
plus prisée par les cadres et des hommes
d'affaires stressés mais aussi pressé et
qui n'ont pas le temps de s'absenter
très longtemps reportage au centre de
deauville marie-hélène bono et si on
loue cet homme à 42 ans agent immobilier
il jongle avec les horaires l'ordinateur
les téléphones et les rendez vous pas
vraiment le temps de prendre des
vacances
ah non non non il faut il annuler
absolument on savait alors cette année
il a choisi de faire six jours de
thalasso à dieu costume-cravate bonjour
peignoir blanc bienvenue à la cure anti
stress avec quatre soins par jour et
beaucoup beaucoup de relaxation première
séance le shiatsu massage chinois même
technique que l'acupuncture le but
réharmoniser les énergies du corps l'eau
de mer c'est la base de tout ça lasse
aux douches au jet pour les contractures
musculaires bains bouillonnants avec
hydromassage pour la détente
bref ici on s'occupe de vous semaine de
vacances
plus tôt la famille en mai
il faisait parler
nécessaire et bénéfique
ce chef d'entreprise de strasbourgeois
en est à sa quinzième thalasso et lui
est devenu indispensable au moment de
liberté qui vous fait énormément de bien
ne s'en rend pas compte combien fait du
bien une thalasso
se relaxer cela s'apprend comme on doit
apprendre à gérer son stress
le stress qui peut avoir de graves
conséquences mais je servais l'estomac
les infarctus et les petites choses sont
les espèces de mal être de la vie
quotidienne
jme tête petit équivalent dépressif etc
etc
six jours de cure coûte 3600 francs bien
sûr la sécu ne rembourse pas et pour les
hommes aussi se sentir bien c'est
essentiel ils viennent chercher les
bénéfices d'un mois de vacances et ils
viennent chercher en fait une hygiène de
vie qui leur permet de retrouver leur
équilibre 30 % d'hommes font une
thalasso contre 70 % de femmes
eux aussi ont de plus en plus envie de
retrouver avec leur santé un peu de leur
jeunesse c'est le temps des champignons
mais si vous n'êtes pas sûr de vous
rendez vous donc au jardin des plantes à
paris où se tient actuellement le salon
du champignon vous dira là bas quelles
sont les espèces et quelles sont les
espèces comestibles surtout et celles
qui ne faut pas toucher car il ya
vraiment danger de mort rommel bonnant
marie pierre cassignard va la trouver
au fait ça ressemble à une cueillette de
champignons
le dimanche matin entre amis sauf que
pour eux les cèpes ou les mourir note
aucun intérêt non ces promeneurs sont
des scientifiques en mission ils ne
rêvent que d'une chose mettre la main
sur les individus les plus repoussants
comme vous voyez il a une forme c'est
assez spécial il s'appelle le pour cette
raison phallus impudique us dégage
vraiment une mauvaise odeur à mélanie
marche qui est en train de le manger pas
toujours visibles les champignons et
pourtant ils sont partout il leur suffit
d'un peu d'humidité et de chaleur
dix mille espèces en france plus d'un
million et demi sur la planète un monde
ni animal ni végétales des champignons
tout simplement et pour exister tous
doivent respecter une règle la vie
commune il y a une relation très étroite
entre le mycélium c'est à dire les
filaments qu'on voit ici entre le
mycélium du champignon et les racines de
certains arbres c'est l'échangé entre
les deux organismes qui permet aux
champignons se développer au salon du
champignon ils sont dans leur assiette
les comestibles les faux amis
les inconnus
on vient de trouver lors des récoltes de
ce salon des petites espèces tout à fait
anodine d'apparence qui aurait fait
récoltés dans les flots du muséum et qui
pour l'instant ne croisait pour une
tarification pour votre cueillette
demain matin un conseil évitez toujours
les champignons aux couleurs vives
beaucoup trop beau pour être comestible
après les vendanges des différentes
appellations françaises ce soir
l'armagnac du côté de nogaro dans le
gers
ici on a reconstitué les vendanges tel
qu'on est pratiqué il y a moins bien
moins d'un siècle encore isabelle de
léon olivier combe alors d'encadrement
élevé les pays avaient le bac et sous
les grèves et on peut commencer à couper
que il faut faire attention ne pas
couper les doigts du corps les enfants
des écoles ont retenu la leçon et avec
eux tous les habitants de laujuzan qui
le temps d'une journée vont retrouver
l'ambiance des vendanges à l'ancienne
aux etats unis
mais pour nous tous et peignait depuis
20 ans ici ce sont les machines qui
vendange mais les familles ont gardé
leurs sécateurs
je suis sur la tête les femmes plonge
dans le passé nous rappelle le bon sens
une charrette et de ton bureau rempli au
rythme des deux les raisins partenaires
le chef on a ressorti pour l'occasion
les deux instruments le fouloir qui est
grave la vendange le pressoir qui lui
fait rendre tout son jules celui ci
coule par terre jusqu'à une pub d'où il
est ensuite pompé c'est mieux matin dans
la presse parce qu'il ya moins de lits
les cadets et la simone large de l'île
d'oléron et on va pas leur âge et
démissionna d'un mois pour 2020 ce jus
sera distillée en novembre content car
maniaque
on le lit du cera que dans dix ou la
science en fait jusqu'à demain soir dans
toute la france si vous êtes à
clermont-ferrand où dans la région vous
pourrez visiter le centre de recherche
agronomique ou des chercheurs ont mis au
point un nez artificiel qui leur permet
de détecter les mille et une odeur d'un
fromage ou encore d'un saucisson
jean-claude allanic jean louis goût
serre les chimistes appelle ça sniffer
et quand on travaille dans un
laboratoire spécialisé dans la recherche
sur l'odeur des aliments savoir sentir
c'est la base du métier à l'âge 35 ter
les décors tout son arôme il faut savoir
que la rome des centaines de molécules
cet appareil but de l'opération
répertoriés chaque molécule qui va
donner son nom au fromage et avec un
chromatographe dresser la carte de
visite informatique d'un authentique
saint nectaire
à première vue cela par un peu abstraite
mais avec une traduction bien senti cela
est beaucoup plus appétissant des barres
de fer des autorités sanitaires ou
d'autres robert surprenante com org ou
la pomme verte ou delà de ce travail de
classification
l'enjeu est primordial pour l'industrie
agroalimentaire
car entre en prenant mieux l'alchimie
d'un produit on peut agir sur ces
molécules olfactives et par exemple
fabriqué pour les français associent
sont plus corsé et pour les scandinaves
un saucisson plus fade spécialisé dans
les aliments ou vous prononcer comme les
fromages et les salaisons ce laboratoire
de l'inra est même équipé d'un nez
électronique un véritable nid artificiel
qui coûte la bagatelle de 250 mille
francs dans notre nez nous avons des
millions de récepteurs qui fonctionnent
en même temps et en copiant la nature on
est capables de construire des systèmes
actuellement qui ont entre 10 et 20
capteurs et lorsque l'on envoie sur ces
capteurs une bouffée d'arômes et vous
faites honneur d'un produit qui ont
banalisé
ceux ci vont répondre fournir un signal
qui sera exploitable à des fins de
reconnaissance net avantage sur l'homme
le nez artificiel n'est jamais enrhumé
et il est totalement objectif mais c'est
là aussi finalement sa limite ne pourra
pas faire c'est dire tout ce qui est une
option de plaisir de choses agréables
j'aime j'aime pas et puis en fait qu'il
ne peut pas ferme en plus c'est que ce
mois ci le derme plaît c'est que moi je
vais pouvoir le manger ça l'appareil ne
fera pas c'est demain à l'aube que ce
chorale dernier grand prix de formule 1
de la saison au japon le titre est en
jeu c'est un duel de fils damon hill le
fils de g et jacques villeneuve
le fils de gilles le canadien jacques
villeneuve qui termine sa première
saison en formule 1 conserve une chance
réelle de l'emporter ce qui sort est un
exploit sans précédent l'an frédéric
bollée à la praille dans leur stand
ils sont évidemment côte à côte mais il
vaut mieux parler
de face à face demain l'un des deux
seulement sera champion du monde
pour les essais damon hill se
concentrent les yeux fermés son père g
en son temps a été couronné deux fois
jacques villeneuve a le regard droit est
clair son père gilles n'a jamais été
sacré lors de l est intense et la piste
de suzuka plein de pièges
les conditions météos compliquer les
choses johnny herbert part à la faute
plus de peur que de mal mais la tension
est à son maximum
jacques villeneuve s'élance il reste
cinq minutes il a déjà le meilleur temps
son but marqué un point en psychologie
sur damon hill les deux pilotes pourtant
se respecte leurs relations sont
d'ailleurs devenus avant nous n'y a pas
de problème de ce côté c'est une équipe
dure à entendre qu'on fait là-bas noir
et je n'aime pas qu'on s'envoie des
vannes dans les médias mais non ce n'est
pas le cas la bataille c'est purement
sur l'eau et sur la piste villeneuve est
irrésistible il signe sa troisième pole
position de l'année sans doute la plus
importante
demain il devra gagner et espérer que
damon hill ne marque aucun point
sous l'oeil du patron ce dernier entre
en jeu il est pour le moment quatrième
temps il peut il doit faire mieux
l'anglais y parvient et se hisse en
première ligne cette fois pas de doute
demain la lutte pour le titre aura bien
lieu
et sûrement à la loyale déception pour
la française jeannie longo elle a été
battue aujourd'hui aux championnats du
monde cycliste en ligne à lugano
terminent dans le peloton à 2 minutes de
la gagnante la suissesse barbara eh ben
et puis la disparition aujourd'hui d'une
des grandes figures du cyclisme français
d'avant guerre
roger lapébie qui s'était éteint à l'âge
de 85 ans il avait remporté notamment le
tour de france 2009 137 la mode
prêt-à-porter printemps-été 97 suite on
passe ce soir d'un garrot à lagerfeld
avant jean paul gaultier autrement dit
nous partons du chic vers le choc nicole
cornu langlois hier en choeur une
collection ensoleillé et sans éclipse
fleurs acidulées et fruits géants soie
multicolores et coton rayé une mode
joyeuse et harmonieuse que les femmes
souhaitent porter du matin au soir
la veste en cuir imprimé python s'ouvre
sur un décolleté sophistiqués
les tweeds artisanaux réchauffe les
robes légères une sensualité discrète
une féminité omniprésente
une manière d'être de séduire qui se
prolongent tard dans la nuit brodée de
dentelle dorée
karl lagerfeld lui révèle tout sans
pudeur traîne suivez-moi jeune homme sur
des robes fils et qu'ils ont déjà piégé
dans glee enfin une robe portable est
vendable
pour faire remonter le chiffre
d'affaires voici des robes noires
longiligne sa vente est plus rassurante
plus pervers jean paul gaultier joue le
tailleur strict et classique qui
s'encanaille très vite
et la provocation s'accélère
ce créateur sait parfaitement doser les
effets l'app est superbement structure
et accompagne aussi bien les collants
brodé que le pantalon fluide raffinés
érotisme suggéré ou sado masochisme de
ses marins cocasse
la robe du soir se porte avec une
panoplie de badges jusqu'au bout et même
avec la mariée jean paul gaultier porte
l'insolence jusqu'à l'incandescence
puis
c'est un conte de fées maintenant un
vrai six jeunes filles de romans dans la
drôme se produiront samedi prochain à
l'olympia à paris il ya une dizaine
d'années elles ont appris à chanter
ensemble pour s'en sortir
c'est peut-être pour cette raison
qu'elles ont appelé leur groupe évasion
louis carzou jean marc giaume ça à part
la gamme c'est une histoire unique digne
des contes de fées ils étaient donc une
fois à romans dans la drôme
une deux trois quatre cinq six jeunes
filles des cités passionné par les
champs las du rapt les donzelles
s'échappèrent vers les couplets a
cappella un rêve trop grand pour une
seule rim alors elles décidèrent de
chanter en plus de valence et de
s'appeler évasion de quoi en étonner
plus d'un
les télécoms
quand j'étais petit et même maintenant
je me dis ce que vous faites c'est ce
que je voulais être c'est trop rose quoi
mieux pas spécialement chanteuse ne se
transforment en zones dans lieu ça nous
a donné envie de chanter l'espoir mais
on cherche pas on voit pas le panneau et
on est banlieue tension du coin f
convient pas au vide de nos spectacles
de nos champs banques et de notre de
nous c'est vrai qu'on a beaucoup de
soutien ici c'est vrai ne l'a par la
mairie mais de la part aussi de la
population dont les gens quand on leur
parle on dit qu'on va faire l'olympia
eh ben ils nous regardent comme un
groupe sérieux comme un groupe qui
marque
car à force d'inspiration et de s'animer
champ des jeunes filles finir par
dépasser le rhône et du haut de leurs
dix ans d'union qui avait vu la
naissance de deux disques elle
poussèrent leurs notes jusqu'à la
capitale
tous passé
et c'est ainsi regarder voix tendue vers
leur rêve d'enfant que les six jeunes
filles rejoignent airs par un beau jour
d'automne le monde des étoiles
dans un instant la météo
nathalie rihouet 20h50 fort boyard 23h30
l'édition de la nuit présenté par
florence dauchez demain 7h dans thé ou
café et catherine ceylac recevra le
chorégraphe roland petit ami dit
n'oubliez pas polémique que michèle
cotta invités entre autres le juge
thierry jean-pierre et puis michel lucas
le président de l'arc
voilà je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée je vous donne rendez-vous à
demain 13h bonsoir